I'm really very pleased with the way
that the UK business in particular is
performed
you know we've inflated our prices
significantly less than our competitors
so if you look at the volume that we've
driven in that performance it's
significant our performance versus the
marketplace and I'm pleased that were
serving 300,000 customers more this year
than we were last year so food price
inflation has come to your rate less
than it has for some of your rivals well
the food price inflation is there for
all of us but we've been very clear that
we don't welcome it and we'll do
everything we can with our supply
partners and ourselves to try and
mitigate that so that it is not passed
on to our customers we don't we don't
stop all of it
but we've been successful in reducing in
increasing prices significantly less
than our competitors how important has
it been for you to reinstate the
dividend today look it's a very
important and significant step I think
it tells a great story about where we
are in the turnaround it shows that
we're firmly on track but it also is a I
think a signal of confidence from the
board in the plans that we've got what
about the health of consumers right now
consumers in a position to withstand an
interest rate rise should we get one
well I think you know you've seen it
like higher the consumer confidence
indicators show that there's slightly
less confidence but I have to say in
terms of their spending patterns and
their buyer behavior there's no signal
that there's been a material change in
in that you know food is very important
to all of us so that tends to be
somewhat more resilient to interest rate
rises but let's see we don't know for
sure
and as Tesco will continue to do the
best job we can for customers whatever
the prevailing economic conditions are
what about jobs Tesco's cut thousands of
jobs this year head office jobs deputy
store managers jobs and so forth is that
process now ended what was part of the
turnaround it's worth saying the very
first thing we did was recruit 8,000
colleagues for stores in order to serve
our shoppers better but it's true as we
turned around the business we need to
lower the cost and we need to simplify
the way that we operate so that's meant
that we have had restructuring in our
head office in our call centers in other
parts of our business so that is the the
difficult part the very difficult part
of driving but
around about the competitive threat
during the last 12 months Amazon has
obviously bought whole foods how worried
are you that Amazon are increasingly
gonna encroach into groceries they've
now got a deal in this country with
Morrison's as well for example I'm not
unduly concerned by I think what we do
as Tesco is we focus really clearly on
what it is we can do to serve Britain
shoppers a little better you know we
have three and a half thousand stores
around the country we have a very strong
delivery business and and if we focus on
that and do that very well that's the
best way that we can be competitive
whatever happens in the marketplace
confidence should consumers be about
food safety standards we just have this
undercover investigation into one of
yours and others chicken suppliers how
is it fair to say that the grocer's are
not looking as closely as standards
within their supplies as BAP they want
to be I don't think it would be fair to
say that at all we're really concerned
as I'm sure the other retailers are
about what was uncovered on Thursday we
launched our own investigation
immediately the Food Standards Agency
launched its own investigation
immediately and they found that there
wasn't a specific issue within there
that supplier has taken the
investigation very seriously as close
the facility retrained all people in all
safety matters so I actually think that
the UK grocery and manufacturing base
take quality really very seriously we
audit all of the factories that supply
to us and that's an ongoing Quality
Assurance that we and indeed other
retailers
I'm sure do